new skills start to appear in melissa
mccarthy's case courage boldness
everything that she wasn't back in the
normal world back in in her basement
office in the CIA it would that vermin
vermin ridden basement office so you
have the reaction and then there's a
part of the movie that we call
connections and connections is the part
of the movie when your characters start
to find unexpected allies and sometimes
unexpected enemies in in Tropic Thunder
the two main actors Robert Downey jr.
who's an Australian playing in
Australian who's playing a black
sergeant in in Vietnam is always at odds
with Ben Stiller's lead actor and they
barely talk to each other they don't get
along but in in the middle part of the
movie they start to actually talk to
each other and it's the first time that
they're actually trying to make a
connection
connections is when things slow down in
the movie where you have heart-to-heart
conversations you you tell the truth
about each other I I guess the one thing
the one caveat that I'd like to put out
there is that all these elements are in
all these comedy movies but they're not
necessarily in the same order
after connections and and new directions
when characters get a what we call the
discovered goal you have disconnections
which is the dark dark night of the soul
and that's usually the part about
three-quarters of the way or for fits
the way through where everything seems
lost and every your hero is is going to
fail and then somehow they they find the
power
the strength to to try one more time and
they win now normally that comes at
about three-quarters of the way
four-fifths of the way through the movie
in Groundhog Day however that moment
that dark night of the soul happens
about midway through it happens after
the sequence in which Bill Murray who
because he's found that the skill to get
whatever he wants by simply being able
to anticipate what's going to happen
because he's living this day over and
over and over again he's able to rob a
truck with full of money he's able to
sleep with all the women in town and
then he gets the idea that he wants to
have a relationship with Andie MacDowell
the producer Rita and even though he
tries over and over again it always ends
with this great slap montage slap slap
slap and now we're only about halfway
through the movie and that's the time in
which he has lost all hope he goes
through this great series of suicide
attempts their attempts because he does
kill himself but he wakes up the next
day in fact Groundhog Day is a really
interesting structure it's basically
structured after the long first act in
which it sets everything up it's
structured like the five stages of grief
of kubler-ross it's there's a very
there's there's denial there's a very
short section of anger and there's a
long negotiation period then there is
depression and finally there's
acceptance but in Groundhog Day there's
three acts to acceptance there's first
getting Rita to believe in him that's an
entire Act then there's the act of
trying to save the old man in which he's
got to come to grips with the fact that
he's not God he's he's simply a man
going through in an impossible situation
and finally there's the final act of
acceptance in which he simply accepts
his
he's never going to live to see February
3rd he's always gonna be living in
February 2nd and he's ok with it he's
found out that the purpose of life for
him is simply to do as much good as he
can in the one day he has so so that's
that's a way of of just understanding
that this framework this structure isn't
a cookie cutter form that must be
followed that all these parts of the
journey happen
they don't necessarily happen all in the
same order or all at the same time the
thought that everything certain things
have to happen on page 10 and certain
things have to happen on page 26 is
probably not a really good way to
approach writing a screenplay
you